good health to héctor mejía with his brief
informative edition in spanish the
school district has decided to
allow some students and teachers to
return to the classrooms the cis and this
announcement that student is prekindergarten to
third grade they will start in a
hybrid program that will consist of classes
face-to-face and remote starting
Monday, March 1, teachers will be able to
return to the classrooms a
week earlier to prepare, the rest of
the students will have to wait
until the second semester,
meanwhile a group of parents have
planned a protest outside the
offices of the  school district the
purpose of the rally is to ask
the district to bring back sports
for students the activities
were canceled due to the pandemic
the rally is scheduled
for 4pm
and the convention center will open
next Tuesday as the second site  of
coronavirus vaccines
the southern health district  of nevada will
manage the facility and for now it
will only be open to people
waiting to receive their second
dose the health district
is also contacting people who have already
been vaccinated to come to this
center to receive their second dose
a reward is being offered  of 10
thousand dollars for information on those
responsible for a massive fire that
destroyed an apartment complex
under construction this happened
last week about the streets escape that
anahí forms and more than two dozen
federal investigators helped in the
investigation
on Wednesday they affirmed that  the fire
was set intentionally and resulted
in more than 30 million dollars in
damage for information on the
reward you can visit our page
and insead dotcom and now with the
weather forecast the clouds and low
temperatures will remain in bayern
for thursday it is also anticipated
rain for tonight with al m  less than a
quarter of an inch of rain
predicted snow will stay in high
elevations over mountains by the
weekend it will start to warm up and
temperatures in the 50s and 60s by
next week i am that mejía and this
was his news brief
spain
[  Music]